[موسيقى]
إنها سفينة سريعة إنها سكة حديدية عالية السرعة
تطير في السماء بسرعة حوالي 80 ميلاً في الساعة.
تعتقد شركة المركبات الجوية الهجينة ومقرها المملكة المتحدة أن لديها حلاً
للمسافرين المهتمين بالمناخ في المستقبل حتى
لو كان يبدو وكأنه شيء من
[  الموسيقى]
الماضية، لقد أعادت الكثير من التراث
إلى المناطيد، وليس هناك شك في
أنها تبدو وكأنها واحدة من بعض
الزوايا، لذلك لدينا القليل من
القلوب والعقول العامة للفوز بها
ولكن الحقيقة هي 3/4  منها
تكنولوجيا الطيران القياسية، فهي تأتي في
غلاف ذو شكل غريب بعض الشيء، وقد تم
تصميم طائرة إيرلاندر 10 للرحلات القصيرة
والرحلات الإقليمية، وهي مليئة
بالهيليوم وهو أغلى ثمناً
وأكثر ندرة وأقل قدرة على الطفو من الهيدروجين ولكنه
أيضًا أكثر أمانًا لأنه غير قابل
للاشتعال.  أن يكون طوله حوالي 300 قدم
أطول من مصعد 747، يصعد 100
راكب على متن الطائرة، ستذهب
إلى مقصورة فسيحة، هناك الكثير من
الضوء يدخل، المكان هادئ، يمكنك فتح
النوافذ، يمكنك النهوض والتحرك
حول المقصورة، كل مقعد يمكن الوصول
إليه  الممر الذي يمكن الوصول إليه بواسطة الكراسي المتحركة
والأشخاص ذوي القدرة المحدودة على الحركة، هذه
التكنولوجيا لن تعني فقط
ضوضاء أقل وفرصة حدوث اضطرابات
وكبائن غير مضغوطة، كما تدعي H أيضًا أن
انبعاثات الكربون ستكون أقل بنسبة 90٪ من
ما يعادلها J على متن
طائرة تقليدية لدى بعض العملاء الأوائل
الذين أتوا إلينا قالوا جيدًا ماذا
عن وضع 16 شخصًا على متن السفينة
وأخذهم في رحلات بحرية ليلية، فهو ينقل
الناس إلى أجزاء من العالم
يصعب الوصول إليها ويتم ذلك
بطريقة تقلل من التأثير على
البيئة  "إننا نمر
بأول طائرة إيرلاندر تخرج من
خط الإنتاج وسوف تنطلق للقيام
بهذا النوع من المهام في أماكن مثل القطب
الشمالي أو في رحلات السفاري، فهي لا تقيد
نفسها بالعمل من مدارج الطائرات، كل ما
تحتاجه هو مساحة مسطحة نسبيًا
ويمكن صقل هذه المساحة ويمكن أن تكون عشبًا
ويمكن أن تكون مياهًا حتى نتمكن من إنشاء
اتصالات جديدة للأشخاص لجعلهم
أقرب إلى المكان الذي يريدون الوصول إليه
على الرغم من بعض
النكسات السابقة، تقول شركة HV إنها الشركة الوحيدة
في العالم التي نجحت في نقل
هذه الطائرة  نوع الطائرة ونعمل
على الإنتاج التجاري
لطائرة إيرلاندر
10. وتتمثل خطتنا في تسليم ما لا يقل عن
24 من هذه الطائرات سنويًا إلى
السوق اعتبارًا من وقت لاحق من هذا العقد